let's talk about why the Syrian
president has been getting VIP treatment
in Saudi Arabia
[Applause]
Assad's been welcomed back into the Arab
League 12 years after Syria was kicked
out because of his violent Crackdown on
protesters
Crackdown turned into a war that's
decimated Syria
the U.N reckons more than 300 000
civilians have been killed around 14
million people have been forced to leave
their homes that's more than half the
pre-war population an Assad and his
regime are accused of carrying out some
of the worst atrocities so for years
he's pretty much been isolated
internationally but now it looks like
things are shifting the admitting Syria
into the Arab League is very much a
symbolic move for Syria and for Assad
itself it also you know gives Credence
to his narrative that he has one law
this normalization sends a very clear
message that you can kill
you can guess them you can precede them
you can detain them you can destroy your
own country but you will still be
welcome so what's going on here why is
this happening now and what does it
actually change
now before we get into those questions
there's some background we need to cover
first up what is the Arab League it's
basically a regional Club right now
including Syria there are 22 members it
was set up in 1945 its stated purpose is
to promote cooperation and stability in
the region but it doesn't have a great
reputation when it comes to actually
getting things done it hasn't been
involved in solving any of the crisis or
the problems that the region have been
through for the last 70 or 80 years so
Syria being welcomed back isn't really
significant because of what the Arab
League does but it's a sign of Assad's
diplomatic rehabilitation in the region
after years of being an outcast he's
back in the room now something else to
keep in mind when we're talking about
Syria is that 12 years of war have left
the country divided although Assad
controls most of the country with the
help of his allies Iran and Russia the
war has reached a kind of stale mate
with zero sign of any political solution
and that helps to explain the Arab
League's decision to readmit Syria
by the consensus that is in the region
that Assad is not going anywhere they
understood that the Arab League
um and Arab Partners need Assad back in
the Arab League more than an Assad
really needs that now this shift in
Attitude didn't just happen overnight
and there have always been some
differences in how arably countries deal
with Assad for example Oman Sudan and
Algeria never cut ties in the first
place the United Arab Emirates restored
diplomatic relation with Assad's
government back in 2018 Bahrain and
Jordan followed soon after but earlier
this year there was a turnaround by
Saudi Arabia and it looks like that's
what made the difference with the Arab
League in May Saudi Arabia said it would
reopen its Embassy in Damascus and the
league voted to let Syria back in the
club without any conditions attached not
all members were on the same page though
Qatar for example said that its own
position towards Assad hasn't changed
even though it wouldn't sound in the way
of the Arab League's decision
now that's all the Diplomatic stuff and
for millions of syrians who suffered so
much from the war it's been hard to
watch it was very sad it was very
painful it felt like a Betrayal
on the 2nd of July 2013 my father was
kidnapped by the intelligence of the
asada regime from our family house in
Damascus my dad was a was a well-known
critic of the regime I spent the last 10
years of my life wondering if my father
is still alive and my family and I
obviously we had to flee the country
immediately after my father's
disappearance and then you know another
Journey started off we had to you know
rebuild our lives from from scratch
and now you see him welcomed by everyone
with the red carpets and he has the
stage to give a speech and preach us on
what happened in Syria and to flip the
narrative that I use of what has
happened
it's very very very painful now you are
normalizing the the world criminal who
is actually responsible for everything
this country has witnessed okay so how
do we explain what's driving all of this
well there are a bunch of reasons we can
point to let's start with Saudi Arabia
right now it's super focused on
developing its own economy and it seems
to be pushing for more political
stability in the neighborhood as a way
of supporting that goal this is all part
and parcel of this de-risking strategy
by Saudi Arabia to create a political
environment in the region that will not
interfere or will impede in any way that
ambitious economic project so for
example we're also seeing the Saudis
trying to get a peace deal in Yemen and
they've recently been patching things up
with Iran their long-standing rival
there's something else to consider about
where Iran fits in remember it's one of
Assad's main allies and some of the Arab
League countries may be calculating that
getting closer to Assad could help
reduce Iran's influence in Syria because
you know the Iranians have gained a
major foothold during the Civil War by
coming to the aid and assistance
ensuring his political survival then
there's the issue of refugees arably
countries like Lebanon Jordan and Iraq
have taken in huge numbers of syrians
and it's been a heavy burden they're
Keen to start sending some people back
to Syria and establishing closer ties
with Assad may help with that too
whether the refugees themselves feel
they've got anything to go back to or
whether they feel safe about returning
while Assad is still in charge those are
separate questions
there were no conditions put on the
Assad regime to do the necessary
economic political and social reforms to
actually allow those refugees to come
back syrians had to flee Syria because
of the Assad regime as long as this
now another thing arably countries are
hoping to get Assad's cooperation on is
captagon
it's an amphetamine type drug that's
causing problems in the region eighty
percent of the world's Supply comes from
Syria it's said to be the country's
biggest export bankrolling Assad's
government and war effort although Assad
denies that this has been the economic
Lifeline to the Assad regime and to the
businessmen and the constituency
surrounding that solution in the Middle
East and Mediterranean the katagon trade
was worth almost 6 billion dollars in
2021. Saudi Arabia is one of the biggest
markets it's become a popular party drug
there Jordan has other reasons to climb
down on the captagon trade the main
issue is not the drugs itself but
actually the weapons being smuggled by
the same networks into Jordan so whether
it's Iran or refugees or captagon there
are different reasons why Arab countries
are Keen to start dealing with Assad
again but it's all a bit unclear still
and there's no actual plan about what
might come next the Arab League
Secretariat has been very clear in that
one there has been no preconditions on
the regime two they said there's there
are no plans there are actually
understandings of the issues that needs
to be addressed but there is no
agreement yet on what this roadmap would
look like and while this has been going
on there's been no change from the US
and Europe when it comes to Syria Assad
and his regime are still under sanctions
so that's going to limit how Arab
countries and companies can deal with
him they read the international scene
and their companies are aware of the
kind of sanctions that can hit them now
if they were to do that with the Biden
Administration basically turn a blind
eye to to that you know I don't know it
all depends on basically what the Assad
regime is going to give back so here's
the thing on one level you can see how
Syria's readmission into the Arab League
probably won't make much practical
difference anytime soon but the
symbolism is a big deal for Assad it
looks like a vote of confidence it's
important for his narrative that he's
spinning at home inside Syria that the
road to religionization of the regime
has started there's also symbolism in
what Assad's comeback represents when it
comes to the Arab Spring the
pro-democracy uprisings that swept the
region 12 years ago
it's kind of like closing the chapter on
the Arab Spring form the Arab Leader's
perspective there is a need to close
this last chapter of an unfortunately
for democracy and representative
government in the region regardless of
whether Assad controls 10 percent of
Syria on 100 of Syria we spent the last
12 years of Our Lives learning
unfortunately the hard way that
um Arab governments or any other
governments do not really care about you
know whether Syrian people want freedom
or deserve Freedom or they have freedom
or not you know on a political level
I think this is to me it feels like the
end of you know the beginning of the end
there are a lot of changes happening in
the region right now including possible
peace in Yemen watch our recent
explainer on that and don't forget to
subscribe so you don't miss the next
episode of start here
[Music]